This expression can be written as the log of base a of r times t cubed divided
by s. Excellent work if you found this log rhythem. We can start by doing the
division of r and s since we have log of a minus another log of a. We simply
divide s into r and combine the logarithms together. Now we're going to use the
power rule to bring this coefficient of 3 up as the exponent for t. So, 3 times
the log of base a of t is equal to log of base a of t cubed. We're adding two
logarithms together that have the same base. So we can just multiply r divided
by s, times t cubed, here. We know t cubed is the same thing as t cubed divided
by 1. So when I multiply these fractions together, I just multiply their
numerators to get r times t cubed. And we multiply the denominators s and 1 to
get s. Here's our single logarithm.